Transcriber: Haifaa Ali
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
مرحبًا!
وُلدت وعندي مشاكل بصرية،
لدرجة أنّني خرجت من بطن أمي
إلى العمليات مباشرة.
ولا أريد أن أحدثكم عن حالة
الحزن التي كانت لدى أهلي،
بمعنى كيف سيتعاملون مع حالة كهذه؟
لكن كان لديهم إيمان
أنّه من الممكن أن أتحسن.
كانت أمي تخبرني بأني كنت ذكيًا في صغري.
كانت تُجلسني عندها في المطبخ،
وتعرّفني على الأشكال عن طريق اللمس.
كنت ألعب بالصحون والأشواك والملاعق،
أصنفهم وأقلبهم وأثير الفوضى في المطبخ.
كبرت وأصبح يتوجّب عليّ دخول الروضة،
لكن المكان الذي نسكنه في قلقيلية،
لم يكن به مكان مناسب للمكفوفين.
فوضعني أهلي في روضة في البلد،
ومكثتُ فيها لمدة سنة،
لكن لم تُفلح أموري كثيرًا.
سمع أهلي عن مكان مناسب للمكفوفين
يقدّم الرعاية والاهتمام لهم،
لكنّه كان برام الله،
ولا يمكنكم تخيّل هذا التحدي،
أناس عندهم طفل يرى ولا يرى!
هل يضعون هذا الطفل الصغير ذا الخمس سنوات
بمكان يبعُد حوالي ثمانين كيلومترًا؟!
أم هل يتركونه لديهم،
لكن دون أن يتعلم شيئًا؟!
هنا، كان موقف أبي حازمًا وحاسمًا،
وقرّر أنه يجب أن أتعلّم.
أتذكر اليوم الذي أخذني فيه
أهلي إلى رام الله،
عندما وضعوني في السيارة وذهبوا معي.
كانت اللحظة الصعبة عندما ذهبوا وتركوني،
حينها شعرت بالحنين والحزن.
كانت المدرسة جميلة وممتازة،
وكانت المشرفات والمعلمات،
في مدرسة القبس، رائعات وقد أحببني
إذ كنت ولدًا صغيرًا.
لكن ..
شعور الطفل عندما لا يرى أهله
في أسبوعين إلا يومين هو شعور صعب.
تدرّجتُ في مدرسة القبس،
ومكثتُ فيها عشر سنين.
كنت دائمًا الأول،
وتنقلتُ ما بين احتفالات
وتكريمات وامتيازات.
كنتُ من خلال النظر القليل المتبقي لدي،
أستمتع بمنظر الطريق،
برؤيتي الخاصة.
الطريق الذي ألفته وحفظته،
والذي يقع بين رام الله وقلقيلية.
كنت أستمتع بمنظر الجبال وكأنها ترتفع،
والوديان وكأنها تنخفض.
والشتاء عندما يخفي ملامح الطريق ولا تظهر.
مكثت عشر سنين في مدرسة القبس،
صُقلت خلالها شخصيتي وتطورت،
إلى أن جاءت آخر سنة.. عام 2014،
عندما كنتُ عائدًا في إحدى المرات
من رام الله إلى قلقيلية،
وأنا في السيارة، فجأة..
تنطفئ الدنيا، وتتحول إلى سواد.
حينها التفتُ إلى أصحابي الموجوجين
معي في السيارة وقلت،
يا جماعة، كأنّي أصبحت لا أرى!
بصراحة لم أكن حينها أعرف
ما إذا كنتُ أرى أم لا،
لأنّني عندما كنتُ أنظر
من الشباك كنتُ أرى الشمس،
وأنظر إلى الأماكن التي حفظتها،
فأتخيل أنّني ما زلت أراها.
في الأسبوع الأخير لي في مدرسة القبس،
جاءت عندنا مؤسسة الحق في اللعب،
كانت إحدى الأنشطة اللعب في البلالين،
قلت حينها، أي نعم، هذه هي فرصتي.
سيجعلني هذا البالون الصغير
أعرفُ ما إذا كنت أرى أم لا؟
جلستُ جانبًا وأمسكت به،
وفتحت عيني جيّدًا
ونظرتُ إليه، لكنّي لم أره.
علمتُ حينها أنّني لا أرى.
جاءت العطلة الصيفية بعد ذلك،
وكان يتوجّب علي الخروج من مدرسة القبس،
والانتقال إلى مدرسة السعدية في بلدتي.
أنتقل من مكان كان مخصصًا للمكفوفين،
إلى مكان كبير ليس فيه إلا كفيفين اثنين.
من مدرسة كان فيها 60 طالبًا،
وخمسة طلاب في الصف،
إلى مدرسة كان فيها 35 طالب في الصف،
وستمائة طالب في المدرسة.
قلت حينها، يا إلهي، كيف سأتميّز هنا؟
هل سأتميّز في هذا المكان الكبير والغريب؟
شعرت بالغربة عندما أخذني أبي
أول يوم إلى المدرسة،
وقال لهم: “اعتنوا به".
نعم، قد رجعت إلى قلقيلية،
لكنّني رجعت إلى مكان لا أعرف فيه أحدًا.
لكن قررت ألاّ ألعب دور الضحية،
وقررت أن أجعل هؤلاء السنين
أجمل سنين حياتي.
صرتُ أشارك في إذاعة القرآن الكريم،
وأشارك في الإذاعة المدرسية
وأتفلسف وأتحدّث لهم
عن مشاكل المكفوفين واحتياجاتهم
وميولهم وأشيائهم،
وأقرأ قرآن، وعملتُ في المدرسة
“عجقة أي فوضى”،
إلى أن وصلت إلى سنة التوجيهي
أي الثانوية العامة،
التي قررت فيها أن أتقدّم لامتحان
باستخدام التقنية.
كواحد من أوائل الناس في فلسطين
الذين تقدّموا بهذه الطريقة غير التقليدية.
قدّمت الامتحانات، وحصلتُ على معدل 98.2%.
وكنتُ الأول ليس على المدرسة؛
لا، بل على المحافظة.
(تصفيق)
(شكرًا)
ماذا أخبركم عن هذه الفترة؟!
انشغلنا.. مقابلات وإعلام،
وتلفاز وصحافة ومذياع،
والله أحسست أنّي أشهر واحد في الدنيا.
أجريت معي ستة عشر مقابلة خلال أسبوع،
كان الصحفيون يسألونني:
“مؤنس، أين ترى نفسك السنة القادمة؟
وأين هي وجهتك في السنة القادمة؟”
كنتُ أقول لهم: بيرزيت،
جامعة بيرزيت، تخصص اللغة الإنجليزية.
يوم من الأيام رنّ الهاتف،
“ألو، مَن معي؟”
“جامعة بيرزيت. مؤنس معي؟”
نعم، معكم مؤنس. ماذا هناك؟
“أنت لك منحة تفوق. تفضل عندنا”.
ماذا؟!
جامعة بيرزيت؟!
(تصفيق)
الله!
جميل!
ذهبت إلى جامعة بيرزيت،
وأول يوم التقيتُ برئيس الجامعة،
وقال لي: “مؤنس، لك منحة في أول فصل،
وبعدها تولّ أمرك."
ولم أكذب خبرًا، ظليت أحصل
على علامات امتياز حتى آخر سنة!
(ضحك)
(تصفيق)
كان التحدي في جامعة بيرزيت كبيرًا.
إذا كان في مدرسة السعدية 600 طالب،
فإنّ في جامعة بيرزيت 15000 طالب،
ومساحتها 800 دونم.
يا إلهي، أين سأكون؟ هل سيتميّز فيها مؤنس؟
ماذا أخبركم عن يومي؟
كنت أستيقظ الساعة الخامسة صباحًا،
وأكمل النوم في السيارة،
وإذا -لا سمح الله- كنت مستيقظًا
أستمع إلى فيروز ووديع الصافي.
رجعت أقطع الطريق نفسه،
لكن هذه المرة بنظر أقل.
الطريق نفسه الذي كنت أسلكه
إلى مدرسة القبس،
لكن هذه المرة بنظر أقل، لكن برؤية أكبر.
كنت أصل الجامعة الساعة
السابعة والنصف ثم أشرب القهوة.
وسواء كانت صيفًا أم شتاءً،
الجو جميل في بيرزيت.
كنت أصل إلى المحاضرة مباشرة الساعة
الثامنة صباحًا، ولا أسمح لنفسي بالتأخر.
كنتُ أريد أن أكون الأول،
وكنت أكتب ملاحظات مما يقوله الأستاذ،
وفي أوقات الفراغ كنت أجلس مع الأصحاب،
وأطمئن عليهم وأساعدهم.
كنت أصلُ إلى البيت في قلقيلية
الساعة السابعة مساءً.
كنت أدرس في يومي الجمعة
والأحد فقط، أيام العطلة.
رغم ذلك، أنهيتُ تخصص اللغة الإنجليزية فرع
الترجمة في ثلاث سنوات ونصف بمعدل امتياز.
(تصفيق)
رشحت نفسي لمنصب رئيس
نادي اللغة الإنجليزية في هذه الفترة،
وفزت بالأغلبية 63%.
عملنا نشاطات مع النادي من إفطارات جماعية
ومشاركة في كرة السلة وكرة القدم،
وحصلنا على ميداليات وجوائز وكؤوس،
وشاركنا في برنامج الإرشاد
في دائرة اللغة الإنجليزية
عندما كنا نعطي دورات للطلاب
عن مواد التخصص.
كان هناك ساعات عمل تعاوني،
لكنني كنت لا أترك الطلاب،
كنتُ أقول لهم تعالوا في الصيف،
لا يوجد عمل تعاوني وتعالوا لأشرح لكم.
كلما كان يراني عميد كلية الآداب،
كان يقول: “مؤنس، ما الخبر يا نشيط!”
تخرجت من جامعة بيرزيت،
وقدمت على بعض منح الماجستير في الجامعات،
وحصلت على القبول من جامعات كبيرة،
مثل جامعة ريدينغ في بريطانيا،
وجامعة بروكسل في بلجيكا.
سجلت في مشاريع ريادية مثل “مشروع الجبل“،
ودورة إعداد المعلمين في مركز
التعليم المستمر في جامعة بيرزيت وغيره.
واليوم، أنا مدرس للغة الإنجليزية،
وعندي طلاب متعددين،
حضر بعضهم اليوم مشكورين.
أخيرًا، أودّ أن أقول
أن هذه التحديات والإنجازات
لم يكن وراءها آلة،
بل كان وراءها إنسان،
يضحك ويبكي، يفرح ويضحك.
كان أمامي طريقين:
إما أن ألعب دور الضحية وأقول للمجتمع،
أنّني لا أرى ولا أعرف وانتهى الأمر.
أو أن أختار طريق التحدي الممتلئ بالصعوبات.
فقررت أن أسلك الطريق الثاني.
الحياة اختياران: إما أن ترى الهدف،
أو أن ترى المعيقات.
وأنا أقول دائمًا:
انظر إلى الهدف، وتوكل على الله.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)